you
hello everyone and welcome to
broadcast strategies for high Teeter
protein expression using the X beat show
and xB 293 transient expression systems
presented by Jonathan's Amida Buddha
director cell biology Life Sciences
solutions group
Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm Alexis
Krause of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's and
sponsored by Thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information about our sponsor
please visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
before vegan I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at I mean time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please use the ask a question box to let
us know that you're having a problem
please join me in welcoming dr. zmuda I
will now turn the presentation over to
him
- Alexis and good morning good afternoon
and good evening to all the attendees
thank you for joining us again for our
expression world event and as Alexis
mentioned today I would like to talk
about strategies for high titer protein
expression using our mammalian XP cho
and XP 293 expression systems the XP 293
expression system was first launched
about six years ago at this time and XP
cho almost three years ago and during
that time we've been able to put
together a broad set of data regarding
the best strategies for utilizing the
cho versus the 293 expression systems
and in this presentation today i will go
over some of those strategies as well as
the differences and similarities between
the protocols for the different
expression systems so i'm sure that it
comes as no surprise to anybody on the
call today that biologics today comprise
10 of the top 15 selling drugs and you
see a list of them below so certainly
within biological development protein
expression has exploded over the last
couple of decades and certainly even for
those small molecule compounds that are
not themselves proteins the requirement
for protein has continued to increase
during the drug development process even
for the small molecule of reagents so
when we look at the usage of mammalian
cell lines in the biologics development
process many years ago the heck 293
cells were the workhorse of all protein
expression partly because they were
easier to transect and you could get
reasonably decent protein titers in the
2 9 3 cells whereas the older generation
cho based systems had very low protein
titers often in the 10 to 20 milligram
per liter range for monoclonal
antibodies with the advent of xB 293 we
were able to increase the protein titers
from 293 cells in the range of 3 to 5
fold or in many instances even greater
than that which allowed for the utility
of the X b-29 3 cells to be greatly
enhanced
and provide more protein for researchers
needs about three years ago as mentioned
we launched the xB Chow expression
system and the XP geo transient
expression system allowed for even
higher tighter protein expression than
xB 293 and as you see towards the bottom
of the screen to date xB 293 is often
being used in the very early discovery
target ID candidate generation stage in
biologics development whereas xB Cho is
tending to span the entire development
stage often from discovery all the way
through material for animal trials and
in the bottom right you see that very
recently we have launched an XP Cho
stable expression medium that allows for
large-scale production of stable xB Cho
clones for clinical manufacturing
purposes later this year we will also be
releasing the xB 2 x bt oh I'm sorry
GMP cell banks as well as we have late
last year already release the GMP
XB 2 9 3 cell banks available to
customers
so when we look at the three different
expression systems that we have and on
the far right I will note one of our
newest expression systems the ex BSF
expression system based on sf9 cells
that was released just a couple of weeks
ago we now have three high titer
expression systems between XP 293 XP Cho
and X BSF that cover a broad range of
the typical host cell lines used for
protein expression with the paradigm
being that for any given protein that
you need to express we would hope that
one of these high titer expression
systems would be available to provide
that protein for you and again I will go
into a bit about the paradigm in terms
of which proteins tend to be expressed
in which systems so if we look at an
overview of the X b-29 3 system so this
of course is a human HEK 293 based
expression system with typical antibody
yields up to one gram per liter and the
focus historically has been on antibody
screening and significantly also reagent
and immunogen generation proteins for
structural biology membrane and
intracellular proteins and AAV and again
what's new with the X b-29 3 system as
of today is that last year we did launch
the GMP cells for X B 293 available for
licensing currently when X P Cho came on
the market xB Cho was able to
dramatically improve the protein titer
seen in cho based systems with antibody
yields up to 3 grams per liter or even
higher in some instances typically xB
Cho has been focused on monoclonal
antibodies FC fusion proteins fabs by
specifics and some vaccine work as well
and generally xB Cho seems to do a very
excellent job expressing anything that
is antibody or antibody like including
by specifics and and multi specific
moieties that are very complex it seems
as though the cho cells have a bit more
diversity in their ability to express
some of these atypical molecules
similarly also certain species of
antibodies including most specifically
mouse and rat do not express very well
in the two nine three cells whereas the
cho cells do an excellent job and can
again generate titers in the grand per
liter range for the mouse rat and and
rabid antibodies that will show some
data for a little bit later in the
presentation so again what's new here as
I mentioned is that later this year we
will have the XP Cho GMP bank cells and
we've been able to demonstrate that
compared to the parental choez cell line
that we can typically see two to four
fold greater titers in the stable xB Joe
clones often reaching into the three to
four gram per liter range and pairing
that with our large-scale stable XP gel
media that's available also in an a GT
format for the time when you are ready
to scale up into larger scale the stable
production media will not support
transfection of the cells so it is in
fact made for the expression of the
stable clones but for all cell line
generation work the xB Cho expression
media would still be utilized at it as
it is very compatible with transient
transfection and I will talk just very
briefly about our new x BSF system so my
yo-yo Java from my team will be giving
the next talk and going into great
detail on the X BSF expression system
but we're very excited about this system
because for the for the first time in
the insect world we have developed a
chemically defined and completely still
a free media that allows for high
density sf9 cell growth and very
excellent lots a lot consistency now
that yeast delayed has finally been
removed from the insect media so if we
think about this it is somewhat akin to
serum being removed from mammalian media
many many years or decades ago we now
have a completely defined East elate
free media for the xbs f9
xbs f system when we compare this to our
standard sf9 system we typically see
protein yields three folder or higher
than the standard sf9 system and what
we've seen to date is that there's a
significant focus on both intracellular
proteins as well as proteins that may be
toxic to mammalian cells and certainly a
very large play around vaccines VLPs and
AAV being expressed in the insect system
so again following my talk today there
will be a full session on the XPS f
system so please join if you have
interest also in introducing this third
xB system into your laboratory
so what makes the XP systems unique so
there are many quote-unquote systems out
there for 293 or cho cells most of which
comprise at most a transfection reagent
possibly a media as well however to
truly take advantage of high density
transfection and elongated protein
expression runs one must use more than
simply sells media and transfection
reagents because in those instances if
if we were to transect at a very high
density without controlling those cells
post transfection the cells will simply
continue to grow they will reach their
peak density and they will die off and
you lose all of the Associated benefits
with that additional biomass of
transecting at three five or six million
cells per mil so really what the XP
systems can prize is a full fully
developed system of cells media
transfection reagents our proprietary
expression enhancers and feeds as well
as the DNA vectors to go along with them
to optimize protein expression and it's
only when all of these components are
brought together in this systems type
approach that we can truly get order of
magnitude increases in protein
expression compared to any other systems
on the market so what I'd like to do now
is talk a little bit about both systems
side by side so for the last few years
we've spent a lot of time talking about
xB Joe while xB to 93 has continued to
be a mainstay in many laboratories and
what I'd like to do in this presentation
is focus on both of the the xB systems
compare and contrast and give some tips
along the way for each step in the
protocol so if we look at the two
different cell lines on the Left we've
got the xB to 93 F cells and of course
these are human cells derived from the
Freestyle 2 9 3 F cells they are adapted
for high-density culture and the xB 293
media so these cells will typically
attain about 15 million cells per mil
peak density their doubling time is
about 24
twenty-five hours and the cell diameter
is fairly large at about 18 micron and
these cells similar to the xB Cho cells
will become larger visibly larger during
the expression runs when they're
producing high levels of protein the the
transfection efficiency in the xB 293
cells is is very high so eighty to
eighty-five percent is probably even a
bit of an understatement often times it
can be 90% plus but I do want to point
out here that transfection efficiency is
not nearly the most important part of
these systems so while it is important
and it is one of the pillars simply
getting the highest transfection
efficiency does not necessarily
correlate to the highest protein
production once again because it is the
downstream aspects of the systems that
allow the cells to continue to remain
highly viable and generate significant
protein over many days the XP cho cells
over the years have been shown to have
an exquisitely stable growth and
expression profile at least 230 passages
and many times laboratories carry them
out even further than thirty passages
and we get very nice high-quality
biologically active protein so on the
bottom you can see in the middle pane
what the cultures look like at five
million cells per mil and then into the
right pane twelve million cells per mil
should see essentially no clumping of
the cells even at very high densities so
that is always something to keep an eye
out for that if cells are clumping
oftentimes it can be indicative of
culture conditions that are suboptimal
and and perhaps also temperature
conditions within the flasks or even
perhaps a lack of recovery from from a
particular cell bank
so contrasting that to the xB TOS cell
line so these are a sub clone derived
from our GM peach OS cell banks chosen
for the characteristics of high-density
culture so these cells will reach
greater than 20 million cells per mil
and shape class cultures they have a
very rapid doubling time so about 17 to
18 hours so any of you that have worked
with them you know realize that if you
come in in the morning and your XP show
cells are are not at the density that
you need them to be you need only wait a
few hours and they will be where you
need them for your sub culturing or
expression purposes the cell diameter it
ranges from about 14 microns in routine
culture to about 20 microns during
expression so the cells do become very
large and again we we do have high
transaction efficiency in the 75 to 80%
range with the X perfecta mean show
transfection reagent
we've got stable growth and expression
profiles for at least twenty passages
for the XP cho cells keeping in mind
that because the doubling time is so
much shorter for the XP cho cells that
that 20 passages represents a
significantly larger number of
population doublings compared to the the
x b-29 3 cells and what we've shown is
that we tend to get Cho like like
oscillation profiles that match the
protein being made in the staple cell
line and once again very high-quality
biologically active protein the bottom
you see the X P Cho cells in the middle
pane at 6 million the right pane at 20
million and even at 20 million there's
essentially no cell clumping so that is
one thing that we always want to keep an
eye on the cells should not be clumping
in any of your cultures and if they are
there is further optimization that that
we can work with you to to alleviate any
of those issues
so if we look at the actual growth
kinetics on the left you can see again
xB 293 cell growth so these are just
cells
seated at a half a million cells per mil
allowed to grow in shake glass cultures
and you can see in the red line is the
viable cell density and typically for X
b-29 3 we would transect at 3 million
cells per mil and we typically split the
cells between about 3 to 5 when they
reach 3 to 5 million cells per mil these
cells in this case peaked at about 15
million as you can see and the blue bar
across the top is the viability close to
100% across that time once the cells
reach their peak density they will crash
as you see going from day 6 to 7 and the
viability will will drop accordingly on
the right you'll see the XP show cells
in this case growing up to over 20
million cells per mil in the shape class
cultures before they before they crash
in the viability and the density drops
XP Cho we transect at 6 million cells
per mil and typically we recommend
passenger passage in the cells when they
reach 4 to 6 million cells per mil
although with the XP Cho cells and in
fact with both cell lines it's
preferable to over grow those targets
rather than under grow them so you do
not want for either of the high-density
cell lines and high density cell lines
in general they tend to not like being
split before they get into that early
log phase growth so if if you do have an
instance where the cells over grow even
significantly in the case of XP Cho 10
million or even higher we recommend
simply splitting them back more gently
to about a half million cells per mil
and the cell should recover perfectly
fine we have seen instances where when
cells were over subculture at low
densities for many days in a row for
example when a transaction couldn't take
place and the cells were cut back once
or twice at times those cells will not
recover for you so again it's very
important to get them into that log face
growth before you do you sub culturing
and all of those all of those work
towards having the best possible passage
stability
if we look at the complex ation the
transfection reagents of the two kits
are very different for both of them we
found great utility with pcdna 3.4
vector 4x b 293 typically one microgram
per mil of plasmid DNA is most optimal
whereas X B chose somewhere in the 0.6
to 0.8 micrograms per mil is has been
shown to be optimal and both of them use
the same 3.2 microliters of transfection
region per mil of culture to transect 4x
be 293 optimum is the recommended
complex ation media and 4x bicho its op
de probe serum-free medium 4x be 293
typical complexation timing is at least
5 minutes and up to 20 minutes where you
see good stability in the figure below
whereas 4x bicho having a more powerful
transfection reagent to transfect the
cho cells we typically see complex ation
times of essentially 0 to 5 minutes
so 4x bicho the the nice thing is that
we do the complex ations with cold
reagents so you can literally pull your
reagents out of the refrigerator dilute
your plasmid DNA first we recommend then
dilute your x perfecta me Cho
transfection reagent add them together
and mix by gentle inversion or one or
two general type headings and you're
actually ready to transect your flasks
right away so probably a total time of
maybe 5 minutes start to finish for for
the complex ation and transfection in XP
Cho and I will get into later strategies
for automation given the differences in
the two complex ation reactions
and again what I mentioned earlier is
that very important that the feed and
enhancer so the utilization of the
entire xB 293 and X PTO system is
critical for getting that that biggest
cost cost versus tighter benefit of the
systems so on the left you can see xB
293 when we add the enhancers we can
more than double the protein titers and
even more dramatically on the right and
xB Chow so again when you look at the
control scenario here if you simply
transfect xB Cho cells in xB chill media
they will overgrowth and and they will
make very little protein as they use all
of their energy for growth and they will
eventually crash within a couple of days
so again here when we add our feed and
enhancer in this case we get many fold
improvements in the titer
compared to compared to transfecting
only the cells when we add the feed
enhancer is when we can typically get to
the multi gram per liter titers for for
many antibodies so again very important
to utilize the entire systems the the
benefits will outweigh the costs when
you utilize the entire kit you will get
a significant improvement in your cost
per milligram of protein expressed when
we look at the heavy chain two light
chain ratio for antibodies we typically
see in the two nine three cells that a
one to two ratio of heavy chain to light
chain is optimal for xB two nine three
verses in the Cho cells we see that a
one-to-one ratio of heavy delight chain
seems to be optimal for the for the XP
Cho system so one slight difference
there our positive control rabbit IgG
antibody that we provide as part of the
starter kits or make available
separately is a one to two ratio per xB
to 93 but you can see an XP Cho on the
far right while the one to two ratio is
not as good as one to one it still does
give significant significant tighter and
thus the positive control is suitable
for use with
of systems
when we look at the plasmid DNA
titration in XP to 93 versus XP Cho
there's significant differences here in
that in the two nine three cells we
recommend typically about one microgram
per mil but even a bit more even up to
1.2 micrograms per mil of plasmid DNA
per mil to transfect will give a bit of
a boost in titers whereas if we contrast
this to XP Cho about point six and point
8 micrograms per mil is is the peak DNA
concentration in the XP Cho system which
is quite interesting in that we are
transfecting twice as many cells in XP
choke per mil as we are in XP 2 9 3 yet
because of the X defect amino
transfection reagent we're able to use
significantly less DNA and here you can
see on the right again even at point
four micrograms per mil of DNA we're not
losing significant tighter in the XP Cho
system so again a difference between the
two different cell lines and
transfection protocols
when we look at the workflows xb2 93 for
both of these we recommend the day - 1
subculture to give the cells fresh media
to provide the highest titers from the
systems for those of you that are doing
very small volumes in the XP 293 system
you can actually spin the cells down on
the day of transfection and dilute them
in 100% fresh media to the 3 million
cells per mil for transfection and that
will give you probably in the area of 10
to 20% higher titers that becomes less
possible to do as you scale up but many
labs that are running at small scale
will employ a full media exchange at the
time of transection to provide as much
fresh media and as high titers as
possible in the small scales so we have
a day zero transfection at 3 million
cells per mil again looking at the XP 2
9 3 workflow one day later we add
enhancer 1 & 2 for both of the systems
the enhancer 1 & 2 can be pre-mixed
ahead of addition so that you're only
adding one time rather than adding
enhancer 1 n 2 and in fact we have data
to indicate that you can mix enhancer 1
& 2 together ahead of time keep them at
2 to 8 for even up to a month such that
you can only do a single addition of the
enhancer and feed instead of 2 and then
typically harvesting on day 5 to 7 for X
B to 93 in contrast the xB Cho workflow
we subculture add a minus 1 to about
three and a half to four million cells
per mil those cells will typically grow
overnight to 10 million cells per mil or
higher will then dilute them on day zero
down to 6 million we add on on day 1 the
enhancer and the first feed and then at
this time you have a decision point
whether to go remain at 37 c for the
standard protocol or to shift to 32 c
for the max and high titer protocols for
maximum protein expression on day 5 if
using the max titer protocol we would
add the second feed and then typically
harvest on day 7 for the standard
protocol day 7 to 9 and and around a 10
12 potentially as far as 14 for the max
tighter protocols if you're looking to
generate maximum protein titers so the
one thing that's interesting between the
two systems is how the cells make their
protein so X b-29 3 cells tend to be if
you look at the red curve they express
quickly but they also fizzle out quickly
so xB 293 usually around day five six is
when you're going to reach peak titers
the cells do get they do start
expressing a little bit faster than the
cho cells but the cho cells you'll see
in the three blue line so the dark blue
on top being the max titer followed by
the high titer and light blue standard
titer these these protocols if we look
at the max titer protocol on that day
5/6 of harvest XP chill will actually
Express at very consistent levels as xB
to 93 so we we often get the question
around whether or not you know the the
xB to 93 expression kinetics are faster
or better than Cho and in fact in many
instances it seems that they're quite
comparable at the time of harvest for X
B to 93
however xB Cho allows you as you can see
from day six to 12 or 14 you can get
about another two thirds of protein
compared to where you are at day 5 6 so
you know that really is that additional
benefit of the Cho cells and that
characteristic of them that they can
continue to make protein for such a long
period of time however as you see in the
upper right one does not always want to
go out to 12 to 14 days depending on the
type of protein that you're expressing
again X B 2 9 3 typically five to six
days for staple proteins monoclonal
antibodies secreted proteins whereas X B
Cho probably 7 to 12 days is a sweet
spot for those proteins whereas in both
systems membrane proteins typically we
will harvest in the 48 to 72 hour range
you find the the the best expression at
that time and then intracellular
proteins would be somewhere intermediate
of the secreted stable proteins and the
membrane proteins so I think it's
important to you know understand what
your need is with the protein that
you're expressing and then harvest at
that appropriate time if it's less
stable protein you're going to want to
harvest earlier on if it's very stable
and a body where you're looking
primarily for the ability to bind to its
target you know you can take X btol 12
to 14 days and make as much protein as
possible so the other one of the other
differences between the two systems is
the the clarification of the supernatant
and purification
it shows supernatants can be a little
bit more difficult to work with simply
because the componentry for cho cells is
somewhat different than x b-29 3 cells
so generally an XP Cho on the right you
know we we would recommend to spin the
spin the supernatant sat at 4500 to even
up to 7,000 times G for 30 minutes two
to eight this will significantly clarify
the supernatant and make it much easier
to filter both of these we would then
put through a point two micron p/es
filter and then we typically use for
protein a purification Tris buffers and
there's an application note on this 4x
bicho and then for x bt often these
proteins and antibodies may be going
into animal studies etc so an
ion-exchange polishing step or SEC is
often employed in the XP choke
purification schematic so again here
just representing that from the culture
supernatant you know we the faster you
can spin the better for XP Cho we go
through the bottle top filters or depth
filtration depending on the volume that
you have typically going through for
antibodies the protein aid traps with
either a Tris or are happiest based
binding buffer we have found that some
of the components in the X B Cho system
can stick to the protein a columns when
using phosphate buffers so our
application note provides alternatives
for for cleaner protein a Aleutians and
then again cex our AE x polishing steps
for his tag proteins
many of you that have worked with them
know that some of these higher density
chemically defined media's can impact
his tag purification so there are a
number of strategies that can be
employed to improve purification in X B
293 and xB Cho one is to increase the
the resin to media ratio secondly to
dialyze the supernatant into a
compatible buffer thirdly employing a
strip resistant nickel resin such as the
the excel resin is is a good alternative
and then lastly the potential to
consider an alternate protein tag so
later today we'll be joined by a
scientist that will give a presentation
dennis on the strep tak Dhin system
which is a excellent alternative to
nickel nta and hiss tagged protein
purification so among all of this the
keys again to these systems is simply
matching the volume of culture to
transect
with your flask size your shake speed
and your orbit so what do you think
about the four things that need to be
optimized for any expression system we
want to make sure that our volumes of
media as well as flask size are matched
to the speeds and the orbits of our
shakers so that is critical all of these
systems are high density so they push
the limits in terms of cell capacity and
it is important that you know as a start
these conditions are adhered to and then
as you have more experience working you
certainly can tweak these in different
ways in your labs but for the purposes
of getting started we do recommend to
follow these conditions that are in the
protocols quite closely for your initial
expression runs because that is
absolutely important for optimizing the
systems and then moving out of shake
flasks so the mini bioreactor or the
spin tubes these are 50 ml tubes that
have a gas permeable membrane on them
very popular popular with many labs you
can see here data for XP
using the standard protocol or high
titer with final volumes of 20 to 25 MLS
in the tubes very comparable to the 125
shake flask controls in red and the
conditions on the far right for the 19
25 and 50 millimetre shakers and these
conditions can be utilized as well with
xB 293 the only caveat with XP Cho
because of the higher cell density as
you get to these 20 or 25 mil volumes
you will need to tilt the angle of the
tubes by about 15 degrees to keep the
cells in suspension at the shake speeds
and then next the 24 deep well plates
have become an absolute workhorse of the
protein expression community with the xB
systems one can now generate a fair
amount of protein in three to four MLS
that was not possible previously so
these have really become workhorses the
24 deep well plates we typically
recommend the ones that have the square
or the pyramid bottoms round bottoms
also work well but we and others have
found that the pyramid bottoms tend to
be a bit more robust and give a little
bit better results and viability the
cells actually seem to really like these
plates the viability tends to be as high
or even higher than the shake flasks and
again shown here Forex bicho the control
125 ml flask versus the 24 deep well
plates the standard or high titer
protocol is getting very comparable
titers and in the in the table to the
right you'll see again the shake speeds
are the different shaking diameters a
transfection volume and the final volume
in the in the wells
and then lastly the 96 deep well played
option so this provides about one ml a
final volume of shake speed of about 900
to 950 rpm and what's important here is
that the shaking diameter of 3
millimeters it needs to be an orbital
diameter so some Eliza plate shakers
will will shake in a horizontal axis it
is important that the shakers are three
millimeter orbital and again you can see
highly comparable titers compared to the
125 ml control flask for the 96 deep
well plates and for all of these the
last three scales that I mentioned we do
have an application note online with all
of these conditions so you can refer to
that for your scale down protein
expression needs in terms of automation
I've just take you through this very
quickly for xB 293 the the DNA
transfection reagent complexes are more
stable so they can typically sit around
for 20 to 30 minutes on a deck for XP
Cho because of the quick complex ation
we had to alter the protocol a bit so we
used our amber 15 just as a test case
for automation and what we found and
this is actually quite handy even on a
day to day basis is that what we do here
is that we doubly dilute the plasmid DNA
so in the red panel up top we doubly
dilute the plasmid DNA with the full
volume of opti Pro that you would
normally use to dilute the plasmid DNA
and your transfection reagent so we
doubly dilute the plasmid DNA and that's
very stable so that can sit for long
periods of time and then we would have
the robot actually add the neat x
perfecta mean cho transfection reagent
directly to the Platt the doubly diluted
plasmid DNA we would mix that twice on
the robot with the tips and then
immediately add the complex ation
transfect the cells in the vessels so in
this way we're not pre complexing and
allowing the complexes to sit on the
deck we doubly dilute the plasmid DNA s
and then we have the neat X defect amine
show right at the time of complex ation
mix two times and transfect ourselves
and in fact this is the same protocol
that we suggest
all of the scale-down protocols so that
you're not working with such small
volumes you can dilute out all your
plasmid DNA s first add the X perfect
amine show neat to them and you will
have equivalent titers so many labs
actually do this what we call a one tube
complexation method for all of their
scales just because it allows them to
dilute their plasmid DNA that can sit
for as long as you want and then just
add your neat transfection region at the
time of complex ation so breaking into
some of the expression data what I did
want to note here this was data
generated internally using xB 293 and xB
- Oh max titer protocol for a panel of
rabbit monoclonal antibodies and what we
see in the figure so xB 293 is in the
red bars xB chose in the blue bars and
that we generated about 1.4 to 3.9 fold
improvement in xB Cho versus X b-29 3
for this panel with a mean of about 2.4
fold improvement over xB to 93 one
antibody actually map 19 did not express
it all in xB to 93 but we still got
close to 200 MiG's per liter and xB Cho
and then one antibody actually number 20
didn't express in either system and and
that's unclear as to why at this time
but certainly you can see all of these
rabbit monoclonal share the same
backbone with the exception of their
CDRs then you can see the significant
differences solely in the impact of the
different CDRs in the expression levels
of these proteins and then to help with
the detection of your proteins of
interest early on in in the June to July
timeframe we should be launching these
Pro detect lateral flow strips and in
the bottom left you can see all the
different tags that they're directed
against and these strips typically if we
if we look in the the assay setup it's
about 10 to 15 minutes in your culture
supernatant in the case of the the
middle pane you see a competitive assay
for Mik tag and to the right of that a
GST assay and you can see the test line
that shows up when you have a positive
response and in the far right these are
strips that we actually processed in xB
293 supernatant for rabid IgG and as
many of you know our positive control
for the systems is a rabbit IgG so these
strips will provide a very easy way for
you to see visually the expression of
the rabbit IgG in your systems so they
have a linear range of detection of
about 10 micrograms per liter up to one
MIG per liter and croon supernatant so
this was all done in crude supernatant
and - at the at the higher
concentrations for example the 100 Meg
and 10 you see that there like most
amino acids you do get a bit of a hook
effect where we found great utility for
these is that when we're expressing
proteins for the first time around and
we don't know how well they're going to
express or they or that class has a
history of low expression for given
constructs we can quickly screen the
supernatant at small scale to ensure
that we're getting good protein
expression and then you know maybe
that's one to two days into a
small-scale expression run and then we
can then very quickly scale that up as
opposed to waiting five to seven days
generating titers and then scaling up we
can probably cut almost a week off if we
know that we're making protein at the
small scale we can take those constructs
and then scale them up and then looking
at from that panel of top
[Music]
biologics that I mentioned earlier on
you know these are our four different
biologics so they Herceptin Avastin
Enbrel and FC fusion and you can see as
real-world examples you have these
molecules expressing you know close to
the gram close to or above the gram per
liter range in in XP so for some of
these legacy biologics
in terms of his tag proteins this was
done in XP Chow you see on the Left
panel two different fabs so you see non
reduced very very nice quality of the
fabs and and reduced at about 25 KD
using an antihistamine blot in the
middle you'll see to see terminally hiss
tagged proteins again showing up nicely
from XP Cho and then n-terminal his tags
on the on the far right this slide is a
a case study of one of our one of the
labs that utilizes the XP Cho system and
it and it speaks a little bit towards
you know optimization and those
parameters that I mentioned earlier so
in their very first assay they still got
reasonably good titers of their of their
protein we had a few discussions with
them they did a bit of vector
optimization on their own and then we
simply made sure that the transfection
processes and the cell culture best
practices were being adhered to and from
that first assay on the left to the
optimized protocol we achieved almost an
Eightfold improvement and on the right
you can really see the power of the the
XP systems versus the the older heck 293
or Cho s systems where for these two
proteins one and two non antibody
proteins 750 to 800 mix per liter versus
a maximum of 11 and 60 and then for the
human I Gigi's you know 950 and 360 and
again for human IgG number two no
expression at all in the legacy Chellis
system so similarly this was for FA B
fragments on the left again is this bump
that they were able to achieve by
optimizing then you can see on the right
hand side a very thick band so they were
eventually achieving greater than gram
per liter levels of purified fabs from
the XP Cho system in terms of GPCRs so
this is some data around a GPCR
expressed in PC DNA 3.0 harvested at 72
hours and in both cases of XP to 93 and
xB Cho 32c was shown to be better than
37 C
we didn't see any impact on cell
viability even if we let these
expressions go for longer periods of
time and in fact the expression levels
were quite comparable between XP cello
and XP 293 if you look at the bottom
left to the e.coli reference protein at
around 37 KD that had been used and then
lanes two three four and five are xB two
nine three with different amounts of
plasmid DNA and similarly six through
nine for XP Cho and you can see in terms
of activity both xB 293 and xB Cho are
comparable or better on a per mass basis
to the e.coli control material that has
been used previously
similarly we did some work on an ion
transporter and this was expressed in xB
293 or xB Cho quite difficult to express
here we looked at different different
promoters as well as different
concentrations of DNA whether we had a
three or five prime tag or 37 or 32c and
here interestingly if we look at the
bands the second and fourth band under
xB 293 on the left hand side you see
very strong expression of that protein
actually at 32 C again being better than
37 c even for the 2 9 3 cells whereas we
we actually got very poor expression in
xB Joe and you know one question that I
had here is that this transporter is of
specific to neurons and with xB to 93
having a neuronal origin it is
intriguing to consider whether or not
that may be why for this particular
membrane protein the xB 2 9 3 cells do a
much better job than XB 2 so membrane
proteins are always tricky they they
tend to be different from one protein to
another and require optimization but
these are two too interesting examples
of some some similarities and
differences between the xB systems then
in terms of vaccine development just a
real quick story a group out in UCSD led
by James Xue is generating these
trimeric and very large HIV
nanoparticles as vaccines and just a
snapshot of the data from their paper
typically these were all generated in
tuned
three cells and dr. Zhu took these and
put them in XP Cho and what you see on
the third panel from the right in red is
the xB Cho expressed particle and you
see a single peak versus the two peaks
of xB 293 and on their first go-round
they were able to generate 25 fold
higher particle particle mass in XP Cho
versus xB 293 and then we we had a visit
with their lab we made two to small
suggestions in terms of their shake
speed and temperature and they were
actually able to get up to 60 fold
higher protein expression in XP Cho
versus xB to 93 and they're also showing
that the antigenicity of the xB Cho
derived material is in fact superior to
the 293 material and these particles
they are huge and about almost 50% of
the masses is glycans so these represent
very difficult large protein complexes
that historically have been made into 93
but showed significant benefit in the xB
Cho system so I will just talk for a few
moments about the training materials and
resources that are available both online
and virtually as I as I mentioned for xB
Cho there is an essential protocol guide
as you see on the left that has you know
much of the frequently asked questions
and tips for getting started in XP Cho
captured in that document we also have
the guide to optimizing protein a
purification of monoclonal antibodies
and xB Cho as well as I mentioned the
protocols for the 24 and 96 deep-well
plates and the mini bioreactor tubes for
4xp Cho online the other resources as
well is that if you go on to the X b-29
3 or X be to a website or even YouTube
and you look up X B to 93 or XP Cho on
YouTube there are also instructional
videos online made by Chao an Lu who's
our lead scientist on the XP systems
showing exactly how our labs are set up
exactly what our
protocols and and how the transfection
cell handlings etc are performed in our
lab and they truly are about you know
six to six to nine minutes but they are
very educational in terms of seeing
exactly how we are doing things in our
lab where the systems were developed and
then one of the the newer things that we
released very early this year is our xB
293 and xB Cho online protein expression
protocol calculators so you can you can
see the URL and the in the upper right
here and what these allow you to do
online you can go in and if you if you
look at the bottom left panel you can
select whether you're running X B 2 or X
B 2 9 3 and each of these tabs will walk
you through you know the preparation of
the cells in terms of what what flasks
volumes orbits shake speeds etc
transection of the cells the addition of
the enhancers and feed and then you'll
have the ability to print this out in a
notebook copy that you see on the bottom
right which will have all of your
conditions for preparing transfecting
adding the enhancers and feeds for
reference during the actual performance
of your experiments so a very handy tool
to utilize to get all of your volumes in
one place for your experiments and then
lastly I wanted to also take a moment to
point out you know some of the services
and support that we offer in terms of
the lab coat live virtual training
courses so as you see in the in the
upper right they have the ability to
register for these courses and these
courses essentially are they are virtual
so there are trainings that take place
in a virtual environment and the steps
would be followed in your own lab along
with the guidance of the of the
instructors performing the side-by-side
experiments in our internal laboratories
so this is a great way you know if it's
location wise it's difficult for you
know you to visit our labs or for us to
visit your labs these are
excellent interactive ways to get up and
running with the systems with the
virtual training but again I do highly
recommend you to utilize the resources
online especially the videos because I
think as they say a picture is worth a
thousand words and videos are worth much
more when you can actually see all of
the steps and exactly how they are
performed in our laboratory our
equipment etc which sometimes can shine
significant light on similarities and
differences in the way protocols are
being performed lastly I will just take
a moment to you know provide a special
thanks to all of our thermal partners in
protein expression our D product
management marketing and our field
application scientist teams many of you
on the line I'm sure over the years have
have interacted it either by email
telecom video conference or or many also
in person with myself or my team on the
left you see our R&D team you know can't
thank them enough
many of you know Chow Yin have met with
her extensively at the conferences a
real wealth of information for for all
of our all of our collaborative labs and
many of you also know Henry Chu who has
been in the protein expression field for
for many years now and thanks again we
recently have brought on to field
application specialists one in the EU
region nan yang and Matt McKenna and the
supporting the North America based in
the Boston region but these field
application scientists you know when my
team is not available they tend to be
available for in-person consultations or
again telecoms and answering of email
questions so I would like to thank
everybody there and with that have about
ten minutes left in the hour and I will
wrap up and then allow for any questions
that you may have in the audience and
thank you once again
for your attendance today
thank you dr. zmuda for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is xB 293 is
typically harvested on day six to seven
do you need to wait until day 12 to 14
to harvest X bicho great Thank You
Alexis
excellent question I think I touched on
this a little bit earlier I would say
that again for xB Cho going out to day
twelve or fourteen is one of the
benefits of the system if you have the
time to do so you can generate very high
titer antibodies or stable secreted
proteins but at the same time it's not
always necessary to do so or even
desirable so again for both of the
systems less stable proteins sometimes
coagulation factors for example or
membrane proteins intracellular proteins
you would you would tend to harvest them
earlier on but even the stable secreted
proteins in XP Cho you know if you were
to harvest at that same time as xB 293
you know day six seven eight
the titers in XP Cho will typically be
comparable and in some cases even higher
so it's not always necessary I think we
should not think about xB Cho that
you're forced into a 14-day protocol
you're still going to make very high
levels of protein even if you harvest
earlier and then again to keep in mind
the different classes of protein that
you're expressing because many of them
in the case of both systems you will not
want to push them out to those latest
time points due to potential quality
concerns of the proteins themselves
what is the most important indicator of
optimal performance of the XP Cho system
yeah a great question and again as we as
we look back to some of the slides that
I showed around the key for setting up
the experiments we can give back to them
here so this table again when you're
when you're getting started important to
to follow the guidance provided in the
protocols and for XP Cho the key thing
that you want to look at is that on
about day four or five post transfection
if your viability starts to drop off
that tends to be the primary indicator
that something is just not quite right
in terms of the culture conditions so
that the XP geocells even if the
conditions are not right will hang in
there for four five six days but then
the viability will start to drop so what
you really want to see an XP Cho to know
that you're optimized with your
conditions is that you've got that high
viability throughout the expression run
so that you know even on day 12 14 you
know you may be in the high 70s or 80%
viability if if you start to see again
that drop you know around four or five
days almost exclusively that indicates
that you know some some parameter simply
needs to be tweaked a little bit and
once done that high that high level of
viability will be maintained and the
cells will be healthy and Express high
levels of protein
doctors amid our next question what is
the best strain for a be screening
experiment so again both 293 and Cho
have been used for early candidate
screening and they still are I would say
that the the momentum is moving more in
the direction of Cho so many many bio
farmers are interested in starting with
Cho and and staying there throughout the
entire process which is also part of the
reason that we've offered the GMP xB
geocell Bank as well as the stable
production media for those labs that do
their initial screening in xB Cho and
want to follow their development of that
molecule in the xB Cho cells all the way
from start to finish in terms of
clinical material manufacturer so I
think both of them are good I think if
you're screening human antibodies
they're both good choices if you're
screening meereen antibodies or rat as I
mentioned you really want to move the
direction of xB Cho and then again xB
Cho depending upon the post
translational modifications that may be
important to you and/or the ability to
generate higher titers in smaller
volumes at that screening stage may be
one reason that you would look to go to
xB Cho vs. 293 I think in general xB Cho
does a better overall job of expressing
antibody molecules across the board
whereas the 293 cells can on occasion
run into some antibodies that they they
don't like to express or they express at
very low levels
what guidance can you provide for which
system to use for expressing different
classes of proteins when to use X b-29 3
vs XP Cho so another great question
empirically it's impossible to say you
know we don't have a database of all
proteins out there that have been tested
in all the systems but I would say in
general what we're seeing the industry
trends is that anything that has that is
an antibody or an antibody like molecule
a fragment of fusion very successful at
high titers in XP Cho again the murine
and rat antibodies X b-29 3 still tends
to be very popular for making reagents
you know ligands where you want to have
human-like post translational
modifications but they also do you know
very good job in antibodies and fusions
as well lastly I think in general X b-29
3 seems to still be the go-to for
structural biology membrane protein
expression I think laboratories are very
comfortable with those cells as well as
intracellular proteins although they
tend to be split fairly consistently
between the two systems so it really is
you know hopefully a database of
knowledge can be built in your
laboratories but often times antibodies
and clinical therapeutic candidates in
Cho and and reagent structural biology
etc in 293
on our next question what would happen
if we use two at two nine three t cell
instead of X B two nine three cell so
you know a great question
the 293 typically is an adherent line
there there are some that have been
suspension adapted most likely you know
if you could get the 293 t suspension
adapted into the xB 293 media and
growing I think that it's it's likely
that you would be able to get reasonable
expression probably still not not
anywhere close to with the entire xB 293
system but that is that it that is a
possibility the question that I would
ask up front is is there an absolute
necessity to move to the 293 T line if
you can demonstrate comparability
between the T and the xB 293 and you are
seeing you know better results and
higher titers in the xB 293 that may be
a better way to go also because of the
fact that we have the GMP xB 293 cells
banked that if it became an item where
you were looking to move this into
clinical manufacturer those cell banks
would be available for licensing
opportunities doctors amudha what would
happen if we incubate the cell without
shaking we do not have orbital shakers
adjusted by our incubator yeah so here
you know unfortunately the answer would
be that you would not want to try this
the cells being suspension cells and
high-density cells they need to be
maintained with agitation in the shake
flask
such that we get proper gas and nutrient
exchange exchange for these high density
cultures now for you know for gene
editing things along those lines you can
actually add some serum and these cells
will stick down readily to to tissue
culture plastic and and that can have
some utility for for editing but
typically you would need to have the
Shakers to maintain the cells and the
performance of the cells
we are out of time for questions but I
would like to once again thank dr. zmuda
for his presentation I would also like
to thank Thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2019 please share that
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event also stay tuned for
our next presentation a chemically
defined baculovirus based expression
system for enhanced protein production
in sf9 cells presented by Maya yo Chava
you won't want to miss it that's all for
now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye
you